so I think if you're here at this
conference and you're like me probably
you feel that R has a first class place
within any modern data science team
right you know kind of puzz it use a lot
of R and that was most of my career um
but the thing is is that a lot of the
time that decision is not really up to
you and you can find yourself in a
position where the tools that you kind
of know and love actually you're
prevented for whatever reason from using
them to accomplish your goals right I
wanted to start this out by talking
about one of my kind of larger career
mistakes and aside from going to law
school this is maybe like my largest
career mistake law school still wins um
so I was hired by a company called
socure to build shiny apps and to
improve um their R tooling right R
functions help teach people to use our
better and I was good at that and I was
that so here during this was lucky
enough to be there during a time of
really extraordinary growth so this
company hit right at the right time um
and doubled Revenue basically every year
for about three years um and with that
growth came one important challenge
which is that in order to the way our
business was structured every sort of
marginal increase in Revenue required
more and more data scientists so by the
end I think we were hiring something
like 40 a year and finding uh data
scientists who knew something about
identity fraud and also we good enough
at R was very difficult so the company
at some point decided that we're going
to standardize on python to have access
to a larger hiring pool right around
this time my boss came up to me and said
um Gordon you know I love the work
you've done with with r can you do the
same thing with python what I should
have said was yes of course it's python
you know it's not that far away I know
this problem domain very well um I feel
like I have a good intuition about how
people analyze data I can I can do that
but I didn't do that um and I didn't do
it because I had a lot of doubt about my
own intuition about how to build good
python tools and just kind of like a
basic lack of familiarity um my R skills
were so good at that point that whenever
I tried using python I felt like I was
all
thumbs and since then I've kind of been
wondering like what was it you know that
prevented me from having that confidence
like what what was it that I didn't have
of course my whole whole career people
had been telling me to Learn Python and
I tried I'd take an online course has
built little projects etc
etc and I think there's a couple of
reasons why it's really difficult or I
found it really difficult the first one
is that this goal is just absolutely
terrible advice Learn Python in the
generic sense is a terrible advice
because of course there are many pythons
you know like you talk to somebody who's
a data scientist and they say the
important skill is pandas you talk to
somebody else who is a you know does a
web serving uh project in Python and
they'll tell you that pandas is a
horrible dependency that'll ruin your
life right right so it doesn't really
have any particular meaning and because
it doesn't have any particular meaning
you don't know the answer to a lot of
these questions when are you done you
know what particular value does that
provide to you in the short term and how
do you prove it right and all these
things kind of prevent you from making
progress right it's not a good
goal secondly um R and python are
extremely close
substitutes um they do especially in the
data science space they do almost
identical things you know we just heard
that from plot n right you have ggplot
in R plot 9 in Python right they're
substitutes you can do the same thing
with them and I would say for almost
every task that you can point me to in
Python I could say I can do it an r and
vice versa right and the cost of that
what that means is that um there's this
incredible awkwardness when you're
trying to learn something that's almost
exactly like what you already know right
because you're using it and you feel
like you should already know how to do
this thing right they're close enough
that you feel like you should know it um
but they're far enough away that you
really don't right
and because they're such close
substitutes in the short run it doesn't
feel valuable you don't get that
feedback that you get when you first
start programming or when you start
programming in a language that's truly
different from one you know which is
that I have gained some new ability that
I didn't have before so I learned my
second language was actually react
native when I wrote a mobile application
and that was easy to learn right because
I was able to sort of do something I
couldn't do before write something that
goes on somebody's phone you know that
was amazing can't do that in R couldn't
do it in r
so there's a lot of different ways of
kind of coming up with a better goal for
learning these systems like you often
hear smart like specific something
something actionable I can never
remember lots of different acronyms but
the one I kind of gravitate towards is
really simple which is um you might call
this like value based learning and
really what this means is that you need
something whenever you're learning a new
thing you need to find the part of that
thing that provides you with real value
um really quickly when I say real value
this this is I think crucial right A lot
of times when you learn a new thing you
use a toy example or one that's provided
by um by the sort of generic way of
educating yourself and it doesn't really
kind of do the job because you're not
really stressing you're an understanding
of it you're not trying to accomplish a
goal that you personally care about so
real value here I think usually means in
a in a work context something that
generates money or saves time and it
doesn't necessarily need to be that but
most of the time that's what it is so
picking a part of that project where
you're able to show that to somebody
else in your life your boss or your
coworker and they're impressed they see
that there's some value for themselves
in their organization and the second
thing is that you need to have that part
where you realize that value extremely
quickly I think in a matter of weeks you
should be able to take something from
that from that educational experience
show someone else and justify the time
that you've spent on it I don't know
about yourself but I have a fairly busy
job and two young children and all of my
time is spoken for so I need something
where it gives me that value right away
so why is trying for python a good
option under this framework I think
there's three reasons and this is what
most of this talk is going to be about
but shiny for python is the thing if
you're an R developer you want to
diversify your career you know don't end
up like Gordon like have something where
you're in your back pocket if you ever
end up in this situation uh shiny for
python is the ideal um thing to do
there's three reasons for this the first
is that it gives you something that you
don't have um the second is that it's
better than other python web application
Frameworks and finally you already
mostly know
it so what do you get
right so um and I should sort specify
here that the r shiny application uh
framework is not going anywhere it's the
leader in in our on our team right it's
where features probably land first and
are going to land first for a while um
and we have a huge community of our
users people who have building shiny our
shiny applications in you know
incredible ways doing incredible
extensions so those arn't going anywhere
right so feature-wise it's not like you
get a bunch of features that you don't
have in R but you do get a couple of
things so the first one is you get much
easier deployment in various different
entities right so this is something that
over my career as a shiny developer has
come up again and again and again which
is I build something that's useful great
even impressive and then you kind of go
to deploy it and you run into all kinds
of barriers and these apps these
undeployed apps that live on my laptop
mostly worthless right and our
deployments are a little bit fraught
right because it's um it's a niche
language it's often adding um a
dependency to any of your deployment in
environments and that can be pretty
difficult so you get into a lot of these
questions and whether you think these
these questions are right or wrong valid
or invalid they're things that people
believe and that prevent you from
deploying your apps right devops doesn't
know how to use R will this scale what
happens if you leave who will I hire to
do this right chiny for python doesn't
really have these problems because it's
a kind of it's built on um foundational
python web application Frameworks so
people W will at least think that they
can deploy it and manage it right
because a devops person will look at it
and say oh it's just a python it's an
asgi pyth py application I can probably
handle that right in a way that with
that um when you're trying to deploy an
R application of any kind you can kind
of often run into those
problems second reason is that it's much
easier to integrate into um python the
python ecosystem kind of that's
especially over the last year you've
seen just so many incredible things that
have come out of python Frameworks large
language models things like that and
well it's um you can integrate these
things with something like reticulate in
a lot of way lot a lot of the time like
90 5% of the time that 5% of the time
can be really painful right so because
reticulate runs python in R so it's
adding like two layers of things on top
of your framework um you can kind of end
up in these edge cases that are pretty
difficult not everything works
environments can be Chann challenging
and especially if you're working in
industry it's very hard to get help if
you're having trouble installing
somebody's kind of internal janky python
package and they come over to your desk
and you're like hey I'm I'm trying to
install it in R like whether it's R's
problem or their's they're going to say
it's ours problem right so having
something where you just have a single
um language at runtime is really helpful
for um for integrating those things one
language is
simpler and the final thing is that
proves that you know Python and this is
something that I think is really unique
about building web applications is that
they serve as a kind of visual proof to
other people and to yourself that you
know how to provide value in Python
right even if your code is not the best
right even if you don't feel like you
really know how you do it the fact of
the existence of that artifact um is a
way of sort of proving to other people
in your life that yeah you know how to
do this right and validating it for
yourself the F and the thing about that
proof is that I really do think that the
thing that you will produce especially
if you're somebody who has a little bit
of experience with shiny for R is going
to be really impressive to somebody
who's looked only at python web
application Frameworks because I think
shiny is better and this is something
that I'm probably saying in a little
more Stark way than I would I have said
in other contexts and better of course
means different things to different
people but I work on the shiny for
python team right now I wouldn't be
doing that if I didn't think it was the
best right so I just wanted to clarify
like what do I mean by better and for
this I have another story um which is
after we made this uh transition to
python um we were build we put together
a web applic a web API that was for
people to navigate our machine learning
feature store like get information about
featur change them etc etc it's a great
important thing of centralizing this
this thing that we dealt with all the
time caused a huge amount of friction
and it needed a front end and we sort of
looked around and said okay well we're
at python shop now how how are we going
to build this front end and you know
looked at various different options and
the decision was like we're going to do
it in react we're going to build it in a
you know there's going to be a web
application and JavaScript font end you
know it'll be super pro right we didn't
have any react developers on the team so
this imp implied hiring and hir hiring
implied budget and budget impli implied
approval and 10 months later we still
didn't have this kind of value realized
we didn't have the product right and
that's the thing that I really hate
personally as whenever I've worked on a
data science team is that I want my team
to be able to deliver the whole project
right I don't want to have the situation
where we built the model we built an API
we did something and then there's
another team that we have to wait on or
get Kajol or get approval or get road
map uh space to finish the project and
actually show it to the user right I
want to have something where we can do
the whole thing right this is what shiny
does and I think what makes shiny so
special so the way I kind of talk about
this is an idea you might call
programmatic range right it's it's a
framework that can do a lot of things
and can do it smoothly and a lot of the
other web application Frameworks that
you talk about they sort of say like
look we can do simple things we can do
complicated things but when you dig in
you realize that they're doing the
simple thing and the complicated thing
in totally different ways right it's
almost as is if they like several
Frameworks in a trench coat you know and
there's like you have this simple thing
and then like oh you're a little more
complicated like let's learn a whole new
pattern you're a little more complicated
than that oh we're do a whole new thing
right and shiny is not like that shiny
has the same pattern for every single
shiny app reactivity right so if you
know it we taught I taught a workshop on
Sunday Saturday the things that we
taught them that day first time people
experiencing shiny those are the same
things that are done in the most
complicated shiny apps and so shiny has
this ability to to serve you from very
very simple thing to very very
complicated things so that means for
like that API example um if we wanted to
build a prototype in shiny just to get
get us to that 10 months until we have
that react developer who can build
something real you know that works right
it's fast enough to do that easy enough
to do that but if it turns out we
actually don't want to hire that person
or we can't that Pro prototype can
smoothly grow into the product and shiny
has all the tools for doing it so you
don't need to hire anyone right that's
my kind of definition of better I
guess and um so I just kind of wanted to
give a little bit of of a there's about
20 different python web application
Frameworks I'm not going to go through
all of them but I wanted to go through
the ones that I've sort of seen being
most commonly used in the businesses
that I've talked to um so streamlet is a
very popular one it's a wonderful
language it's optimized for a wonderful
framework it's optimized for very very
simple
applications um and that's kind of their
load star is like let's get the simple
stuff to work and we will go we will
sacrifice anything for that goal the way
they've done this is by running the
entire script from top to bottom on
every user interaction so this is a
little bit like um if you're running a
parameterize or a markdown or something
like that where every time anything
changes the whole thing runs right and
you know if you think about this that's
probably seems pretty inefficient it is
and that's because it's sort of where
their design space is it's very very
close to this beginner experience of
getting something working um but this
means that complex apps in my opinion um
are not really possible Right like at
some point you reach this Cliff with
streamlet where you have to throw it
away right and you cannot you cannot
grow into into a product at some point
right not to say you can't do impressive
things with it but there's a there's a
sort of line where it doesn't work and
simple things are oddly difficult like
updating a slider changing a button
color these things require JavaScript or
at least State Management um Dash um
Dash is uh built around this idea of
statelessness and what that means is
that each uh graph and table and
component of your application has to be
able to do everything independently it's
very kind of difficult to share data
between these two things so if you had a
CSV that generated 20 plots a kind of
usual way of accomplishing that in dash
not the only way but a usual way is to
have that um CSP be read in for each
plot 20 times right and you can sort of
share data but involves caching it in
the browser or storing it into a
database and having it reread and lots
of things like
that um so this is like if you imagine
shiny without reactive expressions or
any reactive value or server State um it
would kind of be something where it's
like pretty flat experience right you
don't have this idea of like caching an
intermediary value and using it in many
places this is important it does solve
an important problem which is Dash apps
are incredibly easy to scale
horizontally you can have one app be
served by many processes on a server or
even many servers so that's it's really
good my guess is that I've never had
that problem I'm not sure that many
people actually do um and finally um
these are kind of the Django flask fast
API the sort of uh combination of an API
layer that's written in Python with some
um front end um this is really good for
um for many kind of larger applications
very steep learning curve and you need
to write and maintain your own front
end so the last reason so those are kind
of what you get right um you get to do
something you can't do and you give your
boss or your company something that they
can't do but the cost side is also
really low because I think most of the
people who are kind of familiar with r
shiny actually already know shiny for
Python and the reason is that when you
kind of are learning shiny you feel like
you're learning an r package right CU
there's only an r package but most of
the concept and things that you're
actually dealing with are sort of
generic parts of the components you can
think about shiny and shiny for R and
shiny for python as being client
libraries to the same general framework
so most of what you know from from shiny
for R is transferable like how
reactivity works when to use reactives
versus observers when to use a module
how to style applications and then the
wonderful thing about today's world is
that chat GPD can really fill in the
rest so if you know how to use chiny but
you don't know how to draw a plot in in
Python like me a little while ago um you
can use gbt to translate your ggplot
code into caborn or pla or whatever you
want so this kind of like uh I think is
a perfect value based learning tool
right to get you over that hump and give
you that confidence that you can
actually build it right um it gives you
value provides integration options gives
your employer value because it does
things that they can't really do right
now and there's a very fast time to
Value because most of the knowledge that
you may already have from the r
framework is transferable over to the
python framework they already an exp if
you're an expert in chiny for R I really
do believe that you're already today an
expert in chiny for python so everybody
go tell Gerald Jared lard that um uh so
we're still in the early stages of sort
of developing this project so I just
wanted to give a little bit of call out
for things that you can do if you want
to jump in so joining the Discord is
great uh porting an R shiny extension
over to python this is a very easy thing
to do um and provides a lot of value
because you already have the API that's
working you already have the JavaScript
which you can use and it's really just
translating the r functions the python
functions um and if you're at an
organization that has a large python
group or just a small python group and
wants to talk to some of the shiny for
python team feel free to contact me in
book a webinar and thank
[Applause]
you